any advice on finding the love of your
life of my life this is this is uh why
alex's single response why any advice
yeah actually this comes from a friend
of mine who's in a really excellent
marriage
with
great kids and family and high demand
life
it it's a decision like at some point
you just priority you just prioritize it
as okay
i'm going to make this happen one way or
another and um you don't force the
discovery of that person but i mean i've
occasionally said hey i think you should
meet this person or that person and um
well it wasn't maybe my judgment was
might have been off but the timing
wasn't right or something but i think
that yeah it's a decision
and it also has to do with life
structure i mean there were years so i
when i was in graduate school i didn't
want a girlfriend i just wanted to be in
lab and i sure i had romantic dating
interests but i wasn't going to meet
them through a committed you know live
together situation
wasn't where i was at and as a postdoc
here things are a little different etc
etc so but at some point it's sort of
like what do i want my daily routine to
look like because ultimately a
relationship
however one structures is going to be
part of your daily routine so at the
point where you're like you know i'd
really love to wake up next to somebody
and do blank and blank together and then
i'd love to
work and then we meet for dinner and
then we you know take the dog for a walk
or take kids out or whatever it happens
to be take a trip but do you have to be
one has to be in the mindset of wanting
to do couple like things
people and a lot of people don't think
about it that way they they either fall
into something
or they
they don't see the benefits of
coupling up i think that the pandemic
um tuned people's awareness to
the fact that some things are indeed
easier on your own
it depends on finances etc etc but
a lot of things are made better
done with other people
100 percent but i also so
i was very deliberately
it's an interesting way to put it like
what do you want your day to look like i
think what what do you want your day to
look like what you want your life to be
i was very deliberately always
uh first of all
happy to be alone like a conscious
thinking
uh i know a lot of friends were just
unable to be alone i'm able to be alone
but i'm much happier with another person
like i'm able to share joy with other
humans
i look forward to the day that our kids
are rolling jiu jitsu and my kids are
you know
hanging out with your kids and
um if that notion sounds
even remotely interesting then
and fun then then it's sort of like you
kind of backpedal from that and you go
how do you get how do you you know
engineer and think from first principles
about love
you